Violence and wool,
the insane group,
Tennessee.
If ics continues,
the Russians are invading Ukraine and the Palestinians and Israelis continue to
slug it out.
Does that make you feel gloomy?
Well died because if you look at the numbers more actually seems to be going out
of fashion while the global population is as an all time high.
It seems that we live in the most peaceful period in human history.
How is this possible?
As of September,
2014 there were four conflicts going on in the world that had caused at least
10,000 people to die since January,
2013 nine conflicts that killed more than 1000 people and 13 that killed more
than 100 since January,
2013 not really peaceful,
but consider this of all the conflicts going on,
none is an active war between countries.
They are either civil wars or local conflicts.
Although civil wars are terrible and cause huge suffering,
their impact is usually way smaller than a war between nations or empires.
When two nations engage in war,
they can mobilize much bigger forces,
have access to all of the state's resources and logistics and almost to all of
the population.
So why have we transitioned from wars between nation states,
two civil wars and loads of it is to do with colonialism and the Cold War.
When the Cold War ended,
a major driver of armed conflict vanish too.
But the breakup of the communist dictatorships revealed new or old tensions and
brought new conflicts in the now freed states,
which often resulted in civil war.
Much more importantly,
in 1945 90 all of Africa,
much of Asia and parts of Latin America were under colonial rule by 1990 all but
a few islands were independent,
but wait,
couldn't you argue that what today's multinational corporations are doing in the
third world is just as bad as colonialism?
Let's look at Congo.
It was established as a colony in 1885 by the Belgian king an area 80 times the
size of Belgium.
Violence committed against the indigenous Congolese and the ruthless system of
economic exploitation had killed about half of the population by 1908 about 10
million Congolese were executed all staff to death.
Millions were mutilated and traumatized.
The economic exploitation of the Congo remains the top priority and forced labor
never really ceased completely until the end of Belgian role in 1960 which is
not really that long ago,
so no colonialism was much worse than vulture capitalism is today and it ended
just two generations ago.
Most of the conflicts that are going on right now are in areas that 60 years ago
we're under foreign control,
but things aren't getting better until 1989 victory for one side in the civil
war was common.
While nowadays,
victories are much rarer.
At the same time,
negotiated endings of jumped from 10% to almost 40% what about the rest of the
world?
Why have nation states stopped attacking each other?
There are four major reasons.
One democratization,
the steady development from autocracy to democracy.
Democracy is hardly ever find each other of all the state against state wars
fought since 1900 only a minority were fought between democracies to
globalization.
War is just not as effective at achieving economic goals as it used to be today.
It's almost always cheaper to buy resources on the global markets than to seize
them by force.
People from other nations are more valuable to us alive.
The dead,
which overall is a pretty new concept.
Three war is so 20th century until World War One wolf [inaudible] was seen as an
inevitable part of the human experience and as a valuable tool which you could
use to achieve goals.
When diplomacy hit a brick wall.
Today we have rules that declared acts of aggression illegal and stipulate that
armed forces only justified in self defense or with the authority of the UN
Security Council.
These rules are still broken,
but today it's harder to do so without sparking opposition and disapproval.
Also,
we have an international court for war crimes in The Hague,
and that's a very recent innovation for borders are mostly fixed now after World
War II.
Territorial wars with Germany start when most countries pledged to accept
international borders and respect to other nations autonomy.
But is all of this just an anomaly or are we on the road to lasting peace?
Truth is we don't know yet.
We need a big enough sample to rule out the historical average,
which is about one or two big wars per century.
We just haven't had enough time since world war two to rule out the possibility
that war is not going away.
If we don't have one major war in the next 75 years,
we can be really confident that humanity is changing.
So you see war might be over.
Yes,
there are nasty conflicts going on in many places,
but overall things are getting better and we can make them even better by
speaking up for peace and democracy.
Okay.